this is the jocko unraveling podcast
episode four with daryl cooper
and me jocko willink and we are about to
pick up the thread
of jocko going to war
i want to read something from tom rick's
book fiasco
in the early part from the earliest part
of the invasion
because i want to give people an idea of
the fire you were jumping into in
september october
2003. so the war started in march
and the conventional forces the iraqis
and the resistance in the cities
uh is is precisely the match for the u.s
military that you think it is and we
burn through them
and uh the
third infantry division gets up into
baghdad quick they take the airport they
make their thunder runs through the city
and the regime collapses very rapidly
that's in march in early april
and this passage is uh referring to a
period now april
into may quote
baghdad was falling apart in front of
the eyes of the u.s military with
buildings being looted and parents
afraid to let their children outside
but no one had orders to do anything
about it
looking back several years later colonel
allen king
the head of civil affairs for 3id spoke
of april 2003 with a slow
chilled tone of horror in his voice
i got to baghdad and was told you've got
24 hours to come up with a phase
4 plan on the night of april 8th
colonel john sterling chief of staff of
3id came to me and said
i just got off the phone with the core
chief of staff and i asked him for the
reconstruction plan
and he said there isn't one so you've
got 24 hours to come up with one
king was stunned he had been asking for
months for just such a plan and had been
told that when the time came he would be
given it
lacking clear orders about what to do
once in baghdad
the third infantry division more or less
stayed in place in the capital
you didn't find many dismounted patrols
with three id recall jay garner a
retired
army general and not one to lightly
criticize his old peers
they kind of stayed with their platforms
that is their tanks in bradley fighting
vehicles
on april 6 lieutenant douglas hoyt a
platoon leader with three id saw looters
for the first time
quote i remembered looking through the
sights on my tank at people and trying
to determine if they were hostile or not
he recalled later
he didn't stop them it was not our
mission at the time
the division's official after action
review states that it had no orders to
do anything else
quote third infantry division
transitioned into phase four
sasso that's uh security and stability
ops
with no plan from higher hq it reported
there was no guidance for restoring
order in baghdad creating an interim
government
hiring government and essential services
employees and ensuring that the judicial
system was operational
the result was a power and authority
vacuum created by our failure to
immediately replace key government
institutions
the president announced that our
national goal was regime change this is
still reading from the third id report
that our national goal was regime change
yet there was no timely plan prepared
for the obvious consequences of regime
change
as a matter of law and fact the united
states is an occupying power in iraq
even if we characterize ourselves as
liberators
because of the refusal to acknowledge
our occupier status commanders did not
initially take measures available to
occupying powers
such as imposing curfews directing
civilians to return to work
and controlling the local government in
populous
the failure to act after we displaced
the regime created a power vacuum
which others immediately tried to fill
now i know that
war is a very confusing thing and nobody
has a plan
after the first punch gets thrown in the
fight
but there were
some decisions made in the earliest days
of this war that i find pretty
inexplicable
specifically because they went against
the advice of the military
and the intelligence establishment that
were made seemingly for ideological and
political reasons
el paul bremer he was the civilian who
was
sent over to head the coalition
provisional authority the cpa the
civilian authority structure in iraq
let's just talk about what you just read
before we even jump into the rest of
this
so
this is you know clearly
massively short-sighted
and there's a couple reasons why i think
that that could unfold
um the way it did and i i'm guessing
um when you get when you execute this
thing
that you think could take a long time
and all of a sudden you've you know you
you're you're
you've got to the top of the mountain
right you achieved your goal
and yet it you did it so quickly that
you don't know what to do next and
and that is absolutely i mean that
when you read that um
it's there's no excuse for it like
there's no excuse
to think there even even if you thought
even if you thought like let's let's say
your thought is going into this thing
hey you know what there the people have
been waiting for this
will get saddam out of there and people
will be
ready to jump for joy even if that's
your assessment
you you have to understand human nature
well enough
to recognize that
what that looks like if you don't
control it
will not be a pretty thing
that that's you to not be able to
recognize that
is a massive shortfall
and it is very short-sighted so
and again when you when you look at a
you know a division commander
or uh
a brigade commander division commander
like yeah they're thinking about it
but believe me they're thinking about
like how we're gonna get up there and
what's gonna happen to my troops and
what am i doing with my dead and wounded
and that
they got some pretty heavy thoughts
there has to be a commander you know the
next the next echelon of command is
should be saying okay cool i got these
guys out there on the front lines that
are going to win this thing for me
here's what we're going to do next you
know i used to tell the way i used to
break down roles and responsibilities
for a seal platoon i'd say look
the the enlisted leadership is handling
the tactical problem that we got going
on right now
the officer is looking to figure out
what the next move is going to be
so what we have in this you know you
expand that out several levels of the
chain of command
and what you get is you got you know
division commanders
brigade commanders battalion commanders
that are pushing up that are there in
this tactical situation to win
the next echelon up the chain of command
should be going okay
what's our next move going to be and
that's what that's the way things are
supposed to work
and clearly there this is a this is a
disaster
and you can see it start to unfold the
uh the civilians
the civilian leadership structure the
dod and um
in the administration they didn't really
expect there to be a reconstruction
problem they did expect
the iraqis to throw flowers at our feet
and thank us for liberating them
and then we can look around and say okay
now that saddam's out of power
you know who are some of the good guys
that we've got in here you you can run
this ministry now
right and so they didn't push anybody
to create a phase four plan for what to
do after we
defeated the iraqi regime right and the
military
at least at the time you know they want
to go in there and kick some ass they're
not
they don't want to have to deal with the
phase 4 plan if they don't have to and
if the civilians
are not pushing them on it they're hap
they were happy unfortunately to
uh to assume that the civilians were
taking care of that that they were going
to send in a guy like bremer and he was
working with uh chalabi and the other
people the provisional government that
we had in place and that
that they had a plan for that yeah and
let me say something else here
when you're when you're in that
moment right if you take if you take
this if you take early on in my
combat career going to iraq what we were
worried about out of the gate was how
we're going to do an assault
that's what we're worried about hey look
after the assault
we do something called sensitive site
exploitation where we
search and we you know we search
everything and we look for everything we
didn't rehearse that
because you know what once we get the
target secure it doesn't really matter
right everything's gonna be fine
like we'll figure it out we want you
want us to look around you want us to
look for computers you want us to look
for any intel that we might find cool
we'll figure it out what we're worried
about is taking down the target that's
what we're worried about
this is the exact same story right what
the
divisional commanders what the guys on
the ground are worried about is
look we need to get this target secure
and once they they figure once we get
the target secure cool
we'll have some time we'll be able to
breathe we'll be able to hey it looks
like people get a little crazy okay
let's let's
let's get a grip on this thing let's
settle this thing down and
we you know let's get this sorted out so
even to say if i'm gonna make another
excuse or if i'm gonna make an excuse
my excuse would be hey look we were
focused on getting the target secure
and that's okay like i get it and yeah
my upper echelon should have been like
okay
you know what hey once you get the
targets here don't worry we gotta we got
another group over here we're gonna come
in and these are the
important things that we're gonna follow
and this is the structure we're gonna
set up and here's how we're gonna keep
civilians from doing bad things and
here's why we're gonna get civilians to
do good things
and here's the money we're gonna pump
into the economy and here's how we're
gonna transition
you know businesses that we set up into
businesses that the civilian sector is
leading i mean this is all
stuff that you could kind of map out
but then you get to a point where you've
got target secure and it's not the way
you want it to be it's not really secure
and so then what you have to do is you
have to take action right so
so this is a good lesson learned and
look it's easy sit here hindsight 20 20.
i would have done this i would have done
that no i'm not going to sit here and
say that
what i am saying is as a leader as a
leader listening to this
you should be thinking okay i
accomplished
my mission the mission i was focused on
i accomplished immediately
you have to say what is my next mission
where is this going
what has changed since i got done
because if you think the battlefield
doesn't change and this
goes for business this goes for life
this goes for everything if you think
that things
aren't going to change you're wrong and
part of the whole
ooda loop right the other loop is you
know you you observe
orient decide and act so you have to do
that you
this isn't just a cool thing to say
like you have to do it and when you look
around and you see things starting to
deteriorate rapidly
rapidly too then
you you have to decide to do something
else and you need to act
i will also say this and you you you the
way you say this
the way you say these things you know
you make it very clear very rapidly like
you just said that you just said rapidly
deteriorating
and you asked me in between before we
recorded you like did you know what was
going on
and like yeah i knew it did not appear
the trajectory the downward trajectory
wasn't as clear as it is right now
yeah as we're reading through it i i'm
telling you
uh the explosion of looting when it
happened
i mean it it that happened
at a wide scale in baghdad almost
immediately after we took that city
uh so that people were tearing pipes out
of the walls of the ministry
it happened so rapidly that it would
have been unreasonable to expect our
forces
to know how to deal with that i mean
bremer paul bremmer the civilian who was
in charge by that time in may
he told the military to start shooting
the looters
and the military told him we're not
shooting looters what are you talking
about
and somebody leaked it to the press and
you know that caused the
effect that you you would think uh but
the military wasn't
we weren't equipped to deal with it yet
i think we had two
light brigades in baghdad at the time
when the looting started and so
these guys are in a city of five or six
million people
two two brigades basically at the time
and we don't know what's
uh going to be happening you know at
that moment
there's another thing that comes into
play here and it's
sometimes i talk about hey if you're if
you're a leader
and you can and you can patrol
you know five kilometers an hour
with a 100 pound rucksack on and so you
then
set up your your plan
so that the whole platoon's gonna do
five kilometers now with a hundred pound
rucksack
you get out in the field they can't do
it so it's a little bit of a blind spot
for you to think that other people can
can do what you're going to do
there's a similar a similar blind side i
just was talking to a client the other
day
where the blind spot is
you're looking at something from a
benevolent position where you think
oh my my leaders they're not going to
worry about
you know their paycheck they're going to
take care of their people
that's a blind spot because just because
you're not worried about your paycheck
and you've got a good amount of money
saved and you're going to do okay
doesn't mean some of your frontline
leaders aren't gonna be like wait a
second
i would rather fire every single one of
my people and still get a paycheck
so there becomes a blind spot because
you don't have
the same values that your leaders do
you don't have the same the first
example is hey i don't have the same
physical
uh capabilities that or my team doesn't
have the same physical capabilities
anymore
as i do so that's a little blind spot
the second one is my
subordinates don't have the same value
structure
so they might make these decisions
different than i would and if i don't
know that
then i just expect everyone to do the
right thing well guess what we have here
here's the culture these americans are
going
hey once we've liberated them they're
going to be excited to start their
entrepreneurial venture that they've
been thinking about
and they are it's a blind spot
yeah the blind spot is when you when you
get rid of the government
the first people that are going to take
action are the people that are looking
to
steal rob you know murder rape
exude their power over the situation and
the
the friendly benevolent person that
would have been excited to open a shop
isn't going to even make you know he's
going to make a half a step in that
direction
and then lock their doors and say i'm
not going outside it's mayhem
the military agreed to go in with fewer
troops than they wanted to go
in with at the beginning because
they were under the impression that they
were going to be reinforced by first
cavalry
relatively rapidly um in april
uh i want to say april 21st is it the
last moment it's a week or two before
first cav is supposed to
uh deploy rumsfeld makes a call decides
that they're not needed
and so they don't go and rather than
having
first first armor division come in and
overlap with
the third infantry division for a while
as primary baghdad force
they decide that once 380 gets there or
one ad gets there 380 is just going home
and so that amounts to no reinforcements
at all
um and then the military believed that
we were going to have access to
uh a good portion of the arrest which by
the way just just throwing it out there
right like you know the difference
between
the the the the bad general and the good
general
is the the good general knows how and
when to employ
his reinforcements and he holds it to
the last minute like he doesn't commit
those reinforcements
when you go i don't need reinforcements
that's not good and and to give that's i
think
first cab is 17 18 000 men i mean that's
a serious force to get pulled
especially when the military at this
point is deployed in iraq
with the expectation that it's going to
be showing up
they're also deployed with the
expectation that they're going to have
access to some of the iraqi security
forces and police
that they're already actively getting
together major general mattis at the
time
is working with a bunch of generals he's
got that famous quote to the iraqi
generals that if any of you mess with me
i'll kill you all
um you know we have a bunch of military
guys
um and civilian staff at centcom who are
working with these iraqi generals who
are like
yeah look i got a bunch of people that
are loyal to me who will do what i say
they're good boys they're not crazy um
let's
let's get this thing together and we can
provide security in the areas that you
know we're used to
and bremer does a few things again
bremer's the civilian authority that's
sent over by the bush administration
um the defense department the bush
administration at this point are not
getting along well with the military the
military feels like they're not being
listened to
at the high levels um
relationships are the most important
thing you know relationships are more
important than the chain of command and
when you have two
organizations that need to work that
need to work together and you don't have
relationships
this is a disaster and it gets worse so
um they
they're having trouble uh the the guy
who's in charge of the civilian
authority at first is a retired general
jay garner
right and he's got a pretty decent
rapport with the generals but
they feel like he isn't pursuing
debatification some other things
some of the administration's priorities
that he's not pursuing aggressively
enough so after a month they call him
tell him he's coming home this new guy
bremer is coming in
i kid you not it sounds like something
out of a out of an onion article
uh paul bremer had to get a two-week
crash course in middle eastern politics
before they sent him over
to be the head civilian in charge of the
iraqi occupation
okay and so he shows up with a list of
things that he's going to do
on day one he uh tells everybody
that he is going to institute a radical
demathification process right anybody
who was rank of colonel and above in the
military
or any equivalent of that in the
civilian sector in a country like iraq
where a lot of the industries are
state-owned
a lot of the you know the corporations
are state-owned
anybody who was in the top three or four
layers of management of any of those
industries
any of the government ministries the
military all this
they're not only fired their pensions
are cut and
they're not allowed to work in public
life and in the public sector ever again
okay so let me jump in um
here's what is awful about
this the way this is unfolding
it happens all the time in the military
it happens in civilian sector two
that someone with not a lot of
experience in a certain arena
for whatever reason gets put in charge
of that arena this is this is a
this happens uh is it
is an ideal case no it's not an ideal
case it happens all the time you know
the u.s
military is set up in such a way
that an officer who got commissioned
after 13 weeks of officer candidate
school
is going to show up on a ship and be
you know in a department uh he's going
to be a platoon commander in the marine
corps or the army i mean he
is going to be in charge of people that
have
vastly more experience than he does it
happens in the civilian sector as well
a a a a kid goes to school for civil
engineering and
then reports to a job site on a big
construction project and he's
he's quote in charge of
these construction guys these four men
that have been working for 27 years
it it's okay these things work
as long as the leader that's stepping in
is humble enough to say i don't know
everything
let me sit back please educate me please
give me your advice on what you think we
should do
please let's formulate a plan together
that makes sense to everyone in this
room
i'm here to support what you guys need
i somebody that comes into a situation
and i don't care if it's something
has been bigger than a platoon but it's
something as big
as this situation i'm telling you right
now
if you put a good leader in that
situation with out
with no experience and with no two-week
course if you put the right person in
there
they would they would have squared this
away i'm telling you that
right now i know this to be i i know
this to be true
like the times when i was telling you on
another podcast like if i tell you
something is 100 i'm telling you
you put a good leader with a good humble
leader
into very challenging situations it'll
be okay
i don't think there's any question that
good leadership could have
changed the whole at this point could
have changed the whole trajectory of the
war
so you get a guy rolling in there
who is not humble here's what actually
happened by the way he comes in with
this demathification order a radical one
uh jay garner the retired army general
who had been who he's replacing says oh
you
you can't do this this is this is going
to put 30 to 50 000
highly influential people the people who
know how to run the industries the
ministries all the managers doctors
professors
you're going to put them all out on the
street and tell them they can never work
in public life again
and bremer says i'm not here to get your
advice on this this is what i'm doing he
says okay well i need backup he goes and
gets the cia station chief
he says come talk to this guy with me
they go in and say oh you definitely
can't do this he said
i'm not having a discussion about it
this is what i'm doing
okay that's what happened a week later
he decides that he's going to disband
the entire iraqi military
the entire interior ministry which is uh
you know the entire police
force secure internal security forces
you're talking about
you know 385 000 armed men
from the iraq military age fighting
males military age fighting males who
are now out of work
um who our military guys mattis talks
about this some of the other generals
talked about this we were working with
them
we had a we had a list of names of iraqi
soldiers 125 000 names
of people who were ready to fall right
back into ranks and assist in
reconstruction
assist in security operations in
different parts of the country
and we didn't have enough soldiers to do
that on our own
right so we sent not to mention the
little things like we don't speak the
language
we don't know the country we don't know
the culture like all those things
he put half a million men influential
people
all sunni by the way for the most part
because that's just how it played out
that's what the previous regime was
on the street and made them pariahs in
society overnight a lot of these are
armed fighting age men um he's ignoring
everybody's advice when he does these
things and he's doing it for you know
the people who are kind of pushing to do
this douglas fight back in
back in washington paul wolfowitz these
are guys whose
they lost ancestors in the holocaust and
they're looking at this
as saddam hussein is hitler um
this is denotification you're not going
to let nazis continue to work in the
government of
but if they've done a little more
history they would find out that we
tried that in germany and by 1949 1950
we were like you know we're going to
have to moderate this a little bit
because these are the only people that
have worked in government for the last
10 years
12 years and so it got to a point where
even then we were like alright you
remember the nazi
party what were you just a junior member
you were a teacher okay fine you can
have your teaching job back even then we
had to moderate
but they were coming at this from an
ideological perspective they had an idea
in mind of how they were going to run
this thing and they were taking advice
from nobody
and overnight you know we've got
hundreds of thousands of young fighting
age men who
in in an honor culture right in a
culture where a man's ability to take
care of his family and be the man the
providers
it's important everywhere it's a whole
different ballgame over there and
the sunni population now feels that
we're coming in there to attack and
assault them
um and we're losing
all this while we're losing control of
the country while
uh we're starting to see killings and
robberies and reprisals
and looting on a wide scale and
uh and those are the conditions under
which against all advice he's making
these decisions
and i mean a lot of iraqis and a lot of
american soldiers paid for those for
that arrogance i
i believe that um
and again this is a guy of all people
that if he should have been listening to
the advice of the people on the ground
it should be a guy who had to get a
two-week crash course on middle eastern
he came out of the you know he was he
was a he was an ambassador
he was a diplomat for a while and he was
a private sector consultant guy you know
he worked and just he was just a
business consultant
once again this is why of all
traits that a leader needs to have
humility is the most important one
over and over and over again and this is
the situation you can see it sickens me
to revisit this and you
think um
yeah you you think all it takes is a
little bit of humility and this
this problem would not have happened
there's another quote i think it's from
patton where he says
the general on the ground is always
right
meaning look when you're in the rear the
general on the front is always right
whatever
whatever the quote is it's like yeah
when i show up somewhere
and i just think i know better than
everybody else
general franks who's the commander of
all our forces at the time
he by a lot of reports can't can hardly
be in the same room as this guy he wants
to ring his neck
so the you got the commanding general of
our forces over there and the civilian
authority over there who can hardly be
in the same room
and then another thing that is
is kind of inexplicable happens over the
course of about a month and a half
the commanding general general frank's
he retires and by i don't want to
you know i don't want to say this
because i don't know what it but there
are several other officers and civilians
who were there at the time who
say that he checked out kind of early um
mentally um and
uh general mckiernan he was the
ground forces commander in charge of
ciflic at the time he gets bounced in
june
so after just a couple months
several other officers the the head of
the army the chief of staff of the army
at the time
um he leaves and to give you an idea of
the
their real his relationship to the
civilians the chief of staff of the army
retires in june or july and
neither rumsfeld the secretary of
defense nor his deputy wolfowitz show up
to his retirement ceremony
okay we're in the middle of the start of
a war and that's the relationship that
they had that they had
rumsfeld needs to replace him he passes
over all the three and four-star
generals
in the army and he calls up a guy who
had retired three years earlier
and puts him in charge which you know is
fine he's a good man
by all accounts he did a fine job but it
gives you an idea of the relationship
that civilians have to the military at
this point
and one thing that really is a problem
with this
is when you have a guy now so now so now
when these new military commanders roll
in
now the guy that quote has the
experience on the ground
is bremer right and since
the new guys coming in you hope that
they have these kind of
humble hey what are we doing tell me
what we need to get done how can i
support the mission here
and now all that does is exacerbate the
problem
the ego problem because you have humble
people that want to help but you have an
ego an ego driven person
that is just driving this agenda and now
doing it with
more authority because they have the air
quotes
they have the experience on the ground
there's a story i remember
from this period it was from may june in
that period
there was an army intelligence officer
who had developed some sources and he
was working on trying to figure out what
the
uh what the imams were saying in the
mosques on fridays he wanted to know
what were they telling the people in the
mosques and so he
gets a whole bunch of information some
of it's good some of it's bad some of
it's neutral whatever and he brings this
to the civilian authorities
and they look at it they just they're
not interested they say that's tactical
bring it to the army
and slay says okay so he brings it to
the army and he brings it to a colonel
who's an intelligence officer
um for i guess this would be three id at
the time
and or rather 180 at the time and uh
he looks at it and he just you know in
the whole stack of intel reports he
finds a couple of the
um of the preachers who are kind of
making anti-american statements and he
says well we have to arrest these people
and the guy's like well look all of the
all the imams have to talk like that we
need to tell the difference between the
ones who are serious and the ones
who aren't right and it got to the point
where he couldn't get anywhere with the
military and he couldn't get anywhere
with the civilian side so he just
stopped bringing these reports in
because he figured he was putting his
own sources in danger
and he wasn't getting anywhere with the
people he were he was bringing them to
and so he just stopped and he told all
the sources just cut loose just forget
you knew me i don't want to get you in
trouble or anything like that
so it's just no community no good
communication going on
yeah and and again if you take a step
back when somebody brings you intel like
that
and your first reaction is you got to
attack them when your actual first
reaction is how can we build a
relationship with these people who have
influence over the civilian populace
that's what you ask yourself
summer of 2003 we've got hundreds of
thousands of fighting age men on the
street
they were cops they were um you know
they were they were
iraqi servicemen they're out of work a
lot of them are already armed
and meanwhile there is a budding
insurgency that's starting to crop up we
don't really know it yet but by the
summer of 2003 they're already paying
500
in operation with a bonus for providing
video of killing american soldiers
and these are people who don't have they
don't have income anymore and
a lot of them are pretty angry about it
and they don't need
um you know some they don't need a
strong
islamist reason to want to go
set an ied somewhere at this point a lot
of them start doing it and
um they start to pick up over the course
of the summer and now you're not there
yet
yeah and and really at this point they
were doing a lot
of mortar attacks a lot of pot shots a
lot of rpg attacks
the ied thing wasn't
it wasn't quite getting it was getting
started but it was very
very young in its in its uh
technological advancements that they
were going to make and there didn't seem
to be any coordination to it
it seemed to be individuals who were
kind of
and i will say that
at you know now looking back we see this
downward spiral
um we see the beginning you know you
know
you see really i wouldn't even say we
see the downward spiral looking back
that's that's that's that's giving
ourselves
we're giving ourselves too much credit
what you see is
okay uh you know when you see uh
you know when you look at a uh uh uh
what's it called a whirlpool
you know what i'm saying you see like a
little bit of movement on the surface
and maybe you notice that it's all
moving in the same direction maybe you
notice there's a little
vector point in the middle of that
whirlpool
it has a little dip just a little dip
but you can't see like the
downward spiral you don't see the vortex
yet
i would say somebody that was really
really paying attention
might have been able to see a little
tiny dip
i think to everyone else to me to my
guys
uh it was these things we weren't
connecting them yet we could barely tell
that there was a move
that there was a that everyone's moving
in the same direction or that there was
a movement in the same direction
so it's still not clear it's very clear
looking back
i mean it's very clear you know when
you're looking back you're like oh yeah
and i remember i remember when they um
when they when they did the dissolution
of the
of the iraqi army and the iraqi police
it was it was kind of like a little bit
of a surprise more than it was
what did you are you kidding me you know
you think you know naively think
okay well i guess you know makes sense
right
makes sense centcom literally got
informed by a written note
so again from my position
platoon commander looking out going
that seems weird but
you're thinking okay well it's kind of
outside your
view not only outside my purview
but you know
i wasn't on the ground yet right i was i
definitely
wasn't you know the the station chief up
there that's monitoring all this stuff
you're looking at it going okay what i
what i don't want to do is sit here
and come across like oh i i told you so
no that would be a lie yeah for me it
was like oh they disbanded
the iraqi army uh it's i bet you know
in my mind i'm thinking okay well
they're probably gonna rebuild it from
the ground up
okay got it whatever
did you start to get an idea in august
that things were changing
so august 2nd or rather i believe it was
the 7th
um al qaeda in iraq announces itself by
hitting the jordanian embassy
just blows the hell out of it 17 dead 40
wounded
august 19th just two weeks later they
hit the u.n building i think they were
in a hotel
and they hit that that side of the hotel
killed 22 wounded over 100 and the un
special envoy for iraq was apparently
this very well
loved i don't know a lot about him but a
very well loved brazilian guy
very well respected and he got trapped
in the rubble and died while people
listened to him scream
and the u.n bugged out they had like 800
people in iraq before that they were
down to 15 within like a month they were
out of there
um and then the end of august
the 29th al qaeda in iraq starts hitting
shia shrines in the south they hit
one in i think there was a celebration a
shia celebration going on in najaf and
they hit
the imam ali shrine down there and
killed 95 people
wounded over 500 people and so they're
at a point now where they're not hitting
u.s
targets they're just hitting they're
causing
they're starting to cause some chaos and
we didn't know who was doing this yet
at least as far as i know i don't think
us intelligence was putting this all
together
you know we didn't have the zarqawi
letter yet we didn't have any of the
videos we didn't we didn't quite know
what was going on but we were starting
to get an idea that something was
changing in august
as you were getting ready to get on that
plane i mean were you starting to
realize you were going over there to get
into a real fight
we knew that things were
bad no i shouldn't even say bad we knew
that it was unstable yeah we knew that
it was unstable
we knew that our guys the seals that
were there were out hitting targets
their work was fairly consistent uh
as i remember i could be wrong but from
what i remember
you know they were like hitting targets
and it was pretty consistent the whole
time
and you know they were getting bad guys
and so here you know here's a here's a
something that i talk about a decent
amount
which is our our impression
my impression and america's impression
was we're hitting targets we're catching
bad guys
there's a finite number of bad guys
and once we catch them the dead enders
yeah yep once we once we catch them okay
well then we'll be done
i hope they don't catch them all before
i get there so i can get some of these
bad guys i mean you remember they had
the deck of cards
here's the guys we need to get and
okay so from my perspective
it seemed to be getting it seemed to be
um there was
i would say the clear the clear
separation was you had
the american flags the kids with
american flags
welcoming and seemingly
very quickly that was over
and we were
i don't know if i want to use the word
the enemy
but we were no longer
we did not appear to be any longer
welcome
but the feel the feeling that i had
what i which i think most people would
agree with
was that the people that were waving the
american flags
were there yeah and they were ready to
wave those flags
we saw them wave flags they've hidden
those flags
there's some bad actors that have moved
in
we need to get rid of them and then then
we'll be okay again
right it was it seemed like a finite
problem that
you know we had a glimpse of like where
the iraqi people's
attitude could be and clearly some
something was going on and we still had
work to do
because there's there's people that are
attacking groups within
iraq and we got to go help the the
people that were waving those american
flags
it almost seems like there was a
mentality i get this from a lot of
civilian leadership too that
similar to what you're saying there's a
there's a finite number of bad guys in
there we have to go eliminate them
and then things will be all right it's
it's almost like saying that we're
thinking of
of of eliminating bad guys
rather than an overarching mission of
providing security
it's like saying once we get rid of all
the gangsters in this town we can
disband the police
yes and you know one one thing i was
going to say as you opened up with or
whenever you were you're reading that um
piece
the immediate thing the immediate thing
you got to do is security for the
populace
that's like the uh that's the that's the
overarching or one of the overarching
goals
of of in counter insurgency first
priority
is we've got to get get security for the
populace
and so the minute that you see the
security for the populace going away
you're like okay
this is bad this is bad but
but to answer your question or to take
that thread a little bit further
yes it seemed like there was a finite
number of now of bad actors
it didn't seem logical
that people and this is again this is
where you get a cultural difference
the cultural differences in america
if you tell me you know that you got my
back
we we that that carries some weight that
means you're gonna stick with me
in iraq especially for people
that you know that what's the expression
they're looking for the winning horse
right
they're going to bet on the win they're
they're they're going to look when they
see the horse that's going to win that's
where they're going to
put their put their bets they see
america rolling in
and that's a isn't that like an osama
bin laden quote have you heard that
quote
no tell me it's something along the
lines of you know we
we will bet on the winning horse like
when we see a horse that's winning
that's the one we're gonna get behind i
mean they live in a country where they
know the consequences of betting on the
wrong horse
exactly i don't think we knew that
yeah and so if you think to yourself
well there was people that were pro
america slash
pro freedom let's just call it
pro-democracy i mean people that
from our perception were on board
we i mean look we saw them pulling down
the stuff when did the statue come down
may
we we see them pulling down the statue
of saddam hitting it with their shoe
which
you know hey we know about their culture
we know that hitting them with the soul
of your shoe is the worst insult you can
give
they're on board they're on our team
there's a little bit of an omen with
that thing though
is uh the iraqis are trying to pull that
thing down and they couldn't do it
themselves
yeah we had to go help them out very
foretelling and um
you know i don't think that those people
who were waving the american flags and
then put them away
necessarily just changed their mind
there were a lot of people that were
angry that we did come in there and
knock off the state without a plan to
provide security afterwards
and they blamed us when things would
happen to them and
and that and that's fine but those
people could be won back
um what they can't be won back from is
when
flying an american flag is going to get
you skinned alive in your home the next
day
and we're not doing anything about it um
and so general absolutely well that goes
back to
that goes back to something we already
talked about which is
if you have to pick a side yeah if you
have to pay if you have
if you have if daryl has to pick a side
side one
is i'm gonna help you build a shop
and side two is if you don't do what i
want to do i'm gonna murder your entire
family if you help build that shop then
whose side are you picking i'll help
build the shop if you can protect me
yeah well that's if you don't see that
protection and that's what took us
another three years to establish which
i'm sure we'll get to
but the choice that we gave them was
like
hey we're going to help you we're here
to help you we'll we'll we're here to
try and protect you
and and also what we have to remember is
man the americans we're we're
we don't we can't we can't discriminate
very well yet yeah
and that's a problem and where i thought
you were gonna go with that
is when you i'll wave the american flag
but then when all of a sudden you put a
main gun around through my
you know through my uh mosque or my
you know the the the grocery store on
the corner or you run
through run over my house i'm not happy
so you add that into the mix along with
all the military age males
that now are out of a job and are
worried that
that they're going to now be the
minority in this country i mean there's
somebody we're brewing up some bad
bad stuff but to answer your question
going in the way it looked to me at the
time was look
we had people waving american flags now
there's now there seems to be some
people that are stepping up to try and
stop that
we we need to go and and get rid of
those people
and help the people with the americans
help the people with the american flags
get their country together so
um as the violence starting to pick up
over the course of the summer
one of the things that we realize we
don't have and that we need is
information
and so i i got to imagine when you
started to show there's a big push for
getting us
actionable intelligence right there this
general abaze big big word
um and right again what does that
actually
mean what that means is a very
short-sighted
business plan which is that because that
well what that there right there tells
you is general abazade is seeing the
same thing i was seeing
which is there's bad guys we need to go
get them what does actionable
intelligence mean
because you can take action intelligence
mean there's a bad guy you go get them
yeah
a a a person that says hey what we need
to do is protect the civilian populace
that's a totally different mindset it's
a totally different mindset
and actionable intelligence means
something completely different do you
think there was also a bias
in we did not have the resources to
protect
protect the civilians across that
country we did have the resources
available to go take out some bad guys
and so maybe we just got tunnel vision
on the thing that
you know that we did have the capacity
to actually
to do it is also a it's a battle of
short-term gratification versus
long-term gratification
and when i go out and get a bad guy
i feel good i feel like i did a good job
i high-five my platoon mates and we say
let's go do it again
so you show up in september october
somewhere in there and
what so what are you told when you get
there what's your mission hey our
mission is to go capture kill bad guys
so somebody's going to deliver you a
piece of intelligence says there's a guy
here
yep we're going to develop the
intelligence we're going to get
intelligence
we're going to marry up intelligence
we're going to collaborate intelligence
we're going to get intelligence
through myriad of different sources
including some of the people that you're
capturing as you go along including some
of the people that were capturing
including sources including you know
the whole nine yards sig in human the
whole nine yards yeah we had a
we had an epic at the time
just it was everything i could have
hoped for
you know here's a target like it's like
almost what you picture in the movies
right
here's a target package you guys come up
with a plan
we literally get a a piece of overhead
imagery
there's a red x on the building go get
go take down this building bring us back
the bring us back to military age males
and you've got a lot of autonomy to plan
this out yourselves
total and unmitigated autonomy and
what's your op tempo
going in all the time the most we ever
did was
i think we did four ops in 24 hours
sleeping during the day and hitting it
up at night
no not even sleeping just going from
target to target like come back
interrogate figure out the next guy go
get him
all right so really really
um and this is mostly around baghdad
95 baghdad we did do some operations in
other areas what parts of bag that are
you talking about like um
everywhere in baghdad so has uh have we
gotten to the point yet where i know in
sprint by spring of 2004 haifa street
starts to be a pretty ugly place
so for everybody out there haifa street
is i don't know a couple miles three or
four mile long
boulevard that runs along the tigris
river in baghdad and on the other side
of the river is sadder city
which is a shiite area and on the other
side it's a sea
shed area it's also like a like a ghetto
yeah
and on the other side of haifa street is
also a heavily shiite area but haifa
street itself
is primarily a sunni uh area i think and
so it kind of became like a fault line
um had that become i mean i've seen i've
seen
a video from spring in 2004 where people
are driving down
undercover reporters driving down that
road and there's just al qaeda flags
off the trees and the uh median yeah um
this is one thing that was
one thing that was not good about this
deployment for me it was good it's not
good it was whatever
it was the way it was the way it was for
me
was we were going to hit targets um
like my next deployment in ramadi i
never left ramadi ramadi's a little tiny
city it's three miles across in baghdad
i
would rarely go to i probably i probably
went to i went different places all the
time
so we were in and out we would go in
we'd we'd be in and out of a target in
20 minutes half an hour maybe 45 minutes
the way most people think it seals opera
the way that's why i'm saying it was
like so um
it was it was awesome you know it was
awesome and
we would we knew like well we knew
sauder city was bad we knew
we knew certain areas we knew about
haifa street but it hadn't become haifa
street yet
like we didn't think of it that way also
because we were staying at the baghdad
international airport
where so for us it was a transit to get
in a bag we weren't living there the
green zone was massive too
the green zone was this massive area and
we'd go to the green zone
and when you're in the green zone it's
pretty um
you're detached right it's not like
being out you know we
we'd sometimes we'd go to do an op
somewhere in in baghdad
we'd pull into some army you know
little checkpoint and there was guys
hanging it out there
a lot of a lot of special forces guys a
lot of sf green berets
hanging it out there little tiny you
know they they'd be in a house somewhere
with a
perimeter around it that they'd kind of
haphazardly set up you know not
haphazardly but they
did put together so those guys if you
ask them they'd be like oh this street
that street
kind of like i'll talk about ramadi like
oh here's this street here's this
neighborhood here's what was bad over
here here's what this building was
like we knew it to that level and the
guys in the platoon knew to even more
detail
and then you'd break down the platoon
you know you had one platoon on one part
of the city and the other between them
they knew everything so for me
like well no haifa street yeah i i
haifa street probably heard about it you
know um but it hadn't become a thing yet
you don't have any territory that's like
yours like it sounds like you're getting
you're some there's a high value target
that's out there somewhere
and okay call up the seal send them over
there and there's not a lot of
structure to you know you're doing this
mission and then that builds on it and
goes to this mission and next and next
and next
well that's always the ideal is that hey
we grab one guy we figure out where
his friend is and we go to his friend
and that did happen okay but a lot of
times
there's also when you look at the
network the network
is not organized it's a network it's a
it's almost like a randomized network
and you got one guy that's got
four or five people in a cell and maybe
he's part of one other guy's
who who who's running another cell so
it's not like a chain of command with
you know 500 insurgents on the bottom
and then one at the top
no it's just splattered bad little
groups little cells
of five six seven bad guys and you know
like you said earlier it's
hey i just got fired i lost my job
i you know i was a platoon sergeant i
still
am in contact with my machine gunner my
rpg
gunner and my uh and my point man i'm
gonna call up you know
ahmed and mohammed and and whatever and
we're gonna put together a little
hit and i know i can get paid and i'll
give them a little bit of money and work
novels and we're in business
yeah yeah so there's a lot of that going
on and at this early point
you've got uh former iraqi military who
are just kind of nationalist insurgents
you got people who are just doing it for
the money
you haven't gotten to that point that we
get to an o5 where al qaeda in iraq kind
of
forces everybody onto the same on the
same page
right so you got all sorts of different
groups and people with varying levels of
commitment
i imagine and so you're doing this all
fall
through the winter and the spring yep
just um
i mean you just you're so jocko's at war
i mean you're you're probably
how you feeling uh yeah i mean we we are
we are just i mean i
and this is interesting and this can
kind of give you some insight
into you know your you're reading this
as if this was so obvious to see yeah
right i'm there i'm in it and in my mind
i'm thinking
i'm happy i'm here i'm happy i'm getting
to do this right now
this will probably be over this will
probably be the only combat deployment i
ever get and thank god
it's this it's this good and the op
tempo is this high and we're doing this
many operations and we're doing our part
right
i felt very good about it that was my
feeling
right through the beginning of april was
was
hey it seemed finite
even even to the actual point that
we had a a giant uh
target board and and i i told my
commanding officer
uh you seen the movie the beautiful a
beautiful mind so you know he had this
crazy looking target thing
i said hey sir in order to because i i
had a hard time
and when you look back you can realize
why i had a hard time
putting this picture together in my head
of what all these groups like
i'm like wait a second is this guy
connected to someone else or we
grab this guy where does this lead to
you weren't the only one at that time
exactly so i say i gotta put this thing
up and we put up this physical board
to be able to visualize everyone we're
going after
and it took up a like a big wall
probably a
probably a 20 maybe even a 25 foot wall
in a in uh in a gp tent
and then you know whatever seven feet
tall and it was covered with pictures it
was covered with strings it was covered
with
you know we put this beautiful mind
thing together so we could actually
i wanted to be able to see the progress
that we were making
and so and we did and we'd put uh uh
a green you know the ghostbusters symbol
like the
thing with a slash through it if we
caught them we'd put a green with a
slasher if we killed them we put it with
a red
and we'd get intel from other units and
other units were captured
and so we started picking away at this
board
and it seemed like
it was a finite thing it
seemed like hey we're here we're making
progress
we're here we'll make we're get you know
look hey in the last week
we've rolled up seven bad guys
and i know we're not the only unit
that's doing this so we got units all
over this country and they're all
rolling up bad guys
this ain't gonna last forever i'm glad
you say that because
part of the impression it's gotten back
to a lot of us who followed the war at
like a
new york times wall street journal kind
of level is that the military
knew that things were not going well and
that we were not getting anywhere
and that the civilian leadership back
home didn't want to hear it and so that
that just
although the military was on who was on
the ground they knew the reality of the
situation
it was just that wasn't getting fed back
because the civilians don't want to hear
but it sounds like things were not that
clear
well we'll get to it in this story
you're gonna see that everything that i
just told you yeah
i am going to have a moment of clarity
when i get to ramadi and it's very
obvious and it's directly related to
what i just said so so i will tell you
this
no that is not accurate yeah and people
on the ground myself included all the
way up through april
we were thinking this is a finite
problem
there are still iraqis out there and by
the way
you know the iraqis that were waving the
american flags
they didn't disappear yeah and we would
get the we would get the smile
and we would get the the high five offer
and we would get the
like we did we did one op in downtown
baghdad in the middle of the day
it was awesome i mean it could because
baghdad was
kind of like um it's like it's it's a
very western-looking city
and at this time there was commerce
there was things going on right so there
was
there was activity and so we went into a
crowded there was cars everywhere it was
like it was like a city it was like san
diego i think people lose that they
forget that these are just cities
so we because at night there was a
curfew so we did a lot of our operations
95 of our operations at night and there
was a curfew
so what that curfew meant was that
people had to
get their work get everything done
during the day so
when we rolled out into baghdad in the
daytime for this one daytime hit we did
in downtown baghdad
it was a zoo it was a zoo
there was cars everywhere there was
pedestrians everywhere there was people
everywhere
and and we were driving by the way in
unarmored humvees
window you know no doors we had taken
the doors off we'd turn our seats
out board so we'd be facing outboard so
we could
address threats if they came up and
we had pre-staged in in the green zone
and we confirmed our intel that the bad
guy we were looking for
was in where we thought he was going to
be which was like in an office building
above a shop
so we we roll down there and this is
like
you know it's it's like going into a
crowded city and here we come
you know and and we looked different
right we were seals we had
uh you know our our humvees were
we had big like we'd built like um
kind of like they look like mad max
vehicles so when we rolled out it was
obvious that we were a little bit
different and then we since we had all
of our
seats facing outboard and we had guys in
the back
we carried guys in the back open open
back vehicles
they look like pickup trucks basically
those and we had a
articulating arms with weapons on them
and so the our vehicles look like
porcupines with
guns sticking everywhere very well
coordinated we drove even though
you know i told you that we hadn't had
much experience in driving as soon as we
as soon as we got hold of it like i also
told you seals the dap and seals figure
stuff out and then we want to do it
really well
so we did that and like my platoon chief
he was a
like an off-road guy and so he was the
one that was kind of spearheading
making those things into mad max
vehicles and putting like bumper plates
on them and
so we could push people out of the way
and
when we rolled into baghdad for that for
this one of these daytime hits that we
did and we did we did more than
one daytime hit but this one was just
awesome
and you know you just see the civilians
are getting out of our way and
we come in we scream and you know scream
into the the
right in front of the building that
we're going into but everyone dismounts
in a matter of seconds
storming in there i mean it was very
uh dynamic and then you know
we we we do our mission and
that's what we were doing and so it
seemed like a finite
thing it seemed like with us and with
everyone else that was doing this
we were going to be able to get ahead of
this and
my point on telling that about the
daytime
was people weren't looking at us
like invaders they weren't looking at us
like we were doing something wrong
you they were kind of fired up man like
they were kind of
they were kind of you know it wasn't you
didn't get the negative
feeling right and i remember the first
time i saw
like a legitimate just
straight up jihadist the first time that
i was
face to face with a jihadist was in
fallujah
and we did a hit in downtown fallujah
and we pulled a bunch of guys off target
because it was like a hotel situation
and we didn't
know how to figure out which guy was the
bad guy we're looking for so i was like
take everyone so we took like 13
military age males off target when is
this this is like
uh probably december november december
03.
and we get the guys we get back to the
the uh
we get back to drop these guys off and
it was actually just an army you know
it's gonna say his marine corps was an
army unit
and the you know
so so now we're turning these guys over
to the to the
uh tactical holding facility
the tiff and when we're you know so we
have them all bagged up we got bags over
their heads
and we got them zip tied and so now
we're going off like taking pictures of
them all
and you know i'm like the guy looks like
a kind of a normal guy whatever this guy
looks like kind of a normal guy whatever
and then like pulled the bag off of one
guy's head and this guy's looking at me
i was like oh
this [ __ ] wants to kill me
that's what's happening right now
and i was like this guy's a straight-up
jihadist
and you know they ran of course and it
was like right you know so
even though i say hey you know it's hard
to tell
who's bad and who's good and
when you run into uh there was a lot of
times where i'd look at someone and be
like
that person wants me to die and but most
of the time
it was that person's you know smiling or
and then you you look it was it was a
bell curve right some people
stoked that you were there some people
filled with hatred a bunch of people
kind of in the middle
not wanting to take one side or the
other because they want to bet on the
winning horse
and that's what we were dealing with but
because you'd see those people out in
the middle of the day
and and not only that like i said in the
daytime guess what they're doing like
when we're driving down the highway
there's cars on the highway there's like
cars there's people there's gas there's
there's people doing things there's
markets are open so you're not
thinking that this is this is desperado
right you're thinking like okay
cool we got some people we got to clean
up those were the things that
indicated to me we have a finite like
that we can win we can we we're gonna
this will be over
this will be over all that commerce is
going away price all that yeah
yeah but at the time commerce people
yeah um
you know little shop set up and i'm not
talking about like one or two shops i'm
talking
massive like a freaking farmer's market
like a farmer's market
like that's what's happening so i'm not
sitting there thinking oh this is gonna
fall apart
i'm thinking cool we'll get rid of these
bad guys and
then these these normal people that are
happy to see us we'll be able to
we'll be able to uh continue to grow and
everything we find and there's no
probably zero chance that i'm going to
come be coming back here on deployment
because this will be over and we'll be
done it was just a few months after you
went in on that fallujah operation
that the four blackwater guys got
lynched in that city mutilated tortured
killed
burned and hung up as a crowd of people
cheered on cheered for it and after that
we didn't go into that city with less
than six thousand marines
so when that happened um
it was like we were like when
when i went to fallujah i think i know i
mean i did
i don't know how many ops we did in
fallujah but it wasn't a lot
what is this about 20 miles west bank
[Music]
another 20 or 30 is ramadi yep okay
um when we went in there we knew it was
bad like
fallujah was bad fellows was bad we
there was no
fallujah was going into fallujah was was
higher risk in our minds than going into
baghdad
baghdad was you it was a very
neighborhood-centric like oh yeah
when you're going over there be careful
kind of like what you said with haifa
street like hey we knew
we'd get into we oh yeah this area is
bad there was this many attacks
we had like the board up with the amount
of attacks that were coming from the
enemy
so um when we knew we were going to
fallujah it was
it was not good and you could feel it
too yeah because you could feel it
because
you roll in there and there's it's
there's not people out on the streets
it's quiet um
not quite in like a peaceful way but
quiet in an eerie way and when you do
see someone
they're looking at you maybe not with
the full born
i want to kill you but not friendly
and you can feel that and you know that
sure
so going in there um
you definitely could could feel that
there was
maybe it was going to take a little
longer there or whatever but
hey even when we rolled up those 13 guys
in fallujah like
most of the guys that i looked in their
eyes i was like oh you know he'll be out
tomorrow he'll understand we just got a
bad guy out of his
you know out of this area cool
the uh the lynching in fallujah was just
a couple days before
you were involved in a pretty important
op um
it was 31st of march i think and around
april 2nd april 3rd
which is getting near to the end of your
deployment
um bremer orders solder's house
surrounded
while you want to tell the story well
there's a couple things so first of all
on the fallujah thing with when the uh
blackwater guys you know i was
you know telling my task you knew
commander hey we can go and he's like i
you know i know
and he ran up to our headquarters
his boss and was like hey you know
chocolates guys
they can go we can go we can go get
those guys down and and they told us no
um they go retrieve them i was like we
will go
and you know this is this is hard to
understand
i don't know if you'll understand but
you know to plan a military operation
you know people
i was raised let me put this way i was
raised on a 96-hour planning cycle
for how long it takes to plan and
prepare for an operation
my boss at some point during my
deployment
said hey jocko if we have like a time
sensitive target
how much time do you need to prepare
and launch and my response after i
assessed it was
15 minutes so so that's where when
you're on an op temple like that
like and that was a no [ __ ] you if we
got
if you wanted us to roll 15 minutes we'd
be in vehicles and we'd be rolling and
we did that on multiple occasions where
it was
hey we got the call i have i've we did
one where i had guys that were
lounging around and they were in
they were in turrets of of our hummers
and like civilian clothes with their kid
on
and you know like just we did operations
where we were in civilian clothes
intentionally that's different
in this particular case like guys had
gone to the exchange or something put on
civvies and
all of a sudden the call came and boom
it's like hey load up so
to think about that 15 minutes we'll
roll and we did it on multiple occasions
so when that happened with those guys in
fallujah you know i'm
like you know we're seeing it on the
news we're hearing about it
and i'm saying hey bo you know to my
boss get us get us permission to go
let's go
and he did his best and they were like
no and the the marines ended up going
to take care of that situation
but you could now things are starting
you know that that was
with all the other things that you
mentioned with the
u.n being attacked with the embassies
being attacked
earlier that march earlier in the march
before then i think
there was a couple shia celebrations in
baghdad and karbala they got blown the
hell out of by aqi
and each one of those were
they weren't they didn't hit me like
they hit like that did when the when the
when it happened when that happened when
the guys got killed at fallujah
um it was okay
they they want to kill us and you know
you felt that before
but they want to kill us and they
ambushed us and you know they
shot rpgs at us and you know but
that was that was a another level
right that was another level that was a
hate that was a hatred
that wasn't uh you know this is the
difference between
whatever the guy that murders his you
know
his his neighbor in a fight
and and you know stabs him and goes oh
god i'm sorry
and you know and the guy that you know
cuts off his wife's head and
and and mutilates her body that's the
difference that's
to me that was the wake-up call of oh
okay
this is this is this is going to get
ugly
a couple days after that happened though
you got a different mission yeah so
uh you mentioned solder so much
also otter you know a very
influential and i use that word
it's not the right word influential you
know you when you think of influential
america you think of somebody that's you
know
let's use words like sane and has you
know smart and has a wheels
wields you know uh a lot of sway with
people in a positive way
so this guy was influential but in all
in a very negative way
um shiite muslim and
he he
he he was a real problem and was causing
problems
and he was a good leader charismatic you
know when you see pictures of him you go
i can see where
you know when you and i talk about what
draws people into a cult-like situation
and a lot of it has to do with being
that leader
this guy's that kind of leader you know
a fiery guy a charismatic guy
he looks he looks kind of crazy
you know and he looks like he could
instill fear in people
and so he was causing problems one of
those guys whose eyes come through in
pictures
yeah so he was one of those people
and we had been targeting him and when i
say we
yes me and my platoon but everybody was
targeting him meaning
tracking him what's he doing he's a bad
guy
can we go get him should we go get him
will you go get him and and now
the the big thing about the big
difference with him was he was a guy
that was a national presence
and really an international there was an
active murder warrant on him out at this
time i believe
yeah so he is but but he's a he's a
recognizable
true he's a political political
leader and a real presence
whereas all these other little cell guys
that i've talked about
these guys were not these guys were
nickel and dime
you know criminals thugs sure they were
running a cell of four guys six guys
whatever
maybe we got some guys that were more
senior i don't even remember but this
guy was a totally different story
this this guy is a totally different
story um you know this would be like
i guess if you wanted this would be like
a you know a
demo you know trump is president right
now this would almost be like the
democratic
challenger yeah or or maybe of two or
three democratic challengers that are
running to be
you know get the nod from the dmc he's
one of those guys at this
at this point at this point some of uh
the intelligence estimates that i've
seen
had his militia up to 10 000 people he's
a powerful guy
and the question was
can we go get this guy and what will
happen if we do
and this idea was getting batted around
the whole time that i was there
you know and there was times we spun up
the target package i don't know if we
well i know we never loaded up to go do
it but we definitely
had you know all right hey let's let's
do some planning on it oh they might pop
oh we might get approval
and now your stock is starting to talk
about and almost every operation that i
did was approved at you know the
the the you know 05
maybe 06 level so this guy was now
getting approved this was like a
much much higher approval yeah it's a
political decision it's a political
decision yeah
so we're going back and forth the whole
time and i never even thought twice
about it you know like okay we'll go get
him not whatever you tell me what to do
man i'll i'll go i'll go do it you know
like we said on an earlier episode man
did you put a target you put a red red x
on a
house in denmark sign me up against
coach
um so we get this
what we get is the the the powers it be
decide
we don't really want to get solder um
out of the gate because we don't know
what's going to happen he's got 10 000
militia
he's got all this influence this could
cause a real freaking problem
a real problem when we've already got a
problem
over here in fallujah you've already got
some news we've already got suny
problems
and and my you know assessment had i
been in charge of everything would have
been like hey well
do we want to rip how about we just rip
the band-aid off
you know that could be one way to look
at it it could also be especially given
what happened
yeah uh so what we finally end up doing
is we get the
we get the go-ahead to go and hit
do a hit and capture one of his
senior lieutenants that's down in nija
that's down in hijab which is the
you know the freaking shiite holy city
yeah you can't it's it's the spot
and we get the we get the order um
that we we get cleared to do this
operation and
it's a pretty straightforward operation
it's kind of what we've been doing the
whole time we've been there
it's a little further away we've done
some operations as i said
outside of baghdad and we'd driven you
know sometimes we drove four or five
hours to get to do a hit somewhere
occasionally but joff was kind of like
that so it was a long
transit to get down there
um but pretty standard hit you know we
rolled in
did it feel that way like did you have
an idea that this is a little bit you
know
this is a little bit different yeah i
mean we we knew it i knew
you know this was this was probably the
first
target that was a true
hvt for us so we
people will throw hvt on any anybody you
know high value target
we got a lot of targets you know
some of them more important than others
and now that i'm thinking back we got
some pretty big targets some pretty
we got some guys that ran some pretty
big cells uh in fact that daytime hit
that we did in downtown baghdad that was
a that guy was running
a pretty decent amount of of bad guys so
we did some good
some good ops well solder himself after
this op goes down lets you know
how high value this guy was yeah so we
go in
middle of the night very quiet um
we set up and i i
knew you knew i always remember this is
that you know we're very
quiet we would always you know put our
stop our vehicles some distance away
from the actual target
and then we would foot patrol you know
very quietly so no one was going to know
we were coming
and and you know plus we'd get there at
you know two o'clock in the morning
whatever
blacked out and whenever
you would do this correctly and you had
a little bit of luck on your side
because bad luck is dogs barking bad
luck is you know
some drunk guy uh on a rooftop
yelling at you there's like there's like
things happen this wasn't one of those
nights very lucky
silence just just quiet and
it's quiet how many are you uh
there's probably i don't know what the
total number is but you know we're
running an assault package so there's
probably
20 assaulters going in the house and
then there's and then there's
you know a bunch of guys driving the
vehicles manning the vehicles and
external security
it's a pretty decent sized package and
so it's all
just dead silent
until that breach goes and then the
breach goes you know everyone wakes up
but it was again we're in and out of
there in a matter of
minutes we were we were good at this
point
we were good so we're in and out of
there in a matter of minutes
and i'm back on the road back on the
road and as a matter of fact
you know this is the first time we did
this as soon as we got on the road we
we uh linked up with helicopters that
came and landed and took him
so that's that's when you know you
that's how i knew like as we were
planning
i'm like oh they're they're really
concerned about this guy if they're
gonna land helicopters
and get this guy into the confinement
because they don't want him with us they
want him
they want him so that's how i knew it
was going to be a
um you know that's that's one of the
ways i knew how important this was
and of course look we knew we know you
know we knew this was one of sodder's
guys
we knew that he was one of his top guys
maybe not as much of a top guy maybe
it wasn't a great test case yeah because
solder went nuts yeah and the whole
country went nuts
and he took his mighty army from sadder
city
went and installed himself in the jaff
and the shiites just
blew up yeah and it was very
bad planning with regards to
putting everyone else in the country in
a posture
to be ready for that because the army
the marine corps
actually also yeah mostly the army
around sauder city
they hadn't been given at least they
didn't appear to have been given
a heads up and even if they were given a
heads up
they weren't quite uh
didn't quite know
what posture they needed to get into
because the shias
they they they started to get after it
hardcore the
uh we had most of our forces around
focusing on baghdad mosul and out west
around fallujah because fallujah one's
coming up right now
and we had a lot of our allies um you
know the poles and the bulgarians some
of our other allies down in a lot of the
southern shiite cities
and they just start getting hammered
right yeah yeah the um
well there's a couple things that
happened the cpa
in in the jave yeah
started to get overrun right
and as that started to happen so we
so we did the hit and then drove back
and it's like a five hour drive
and yeah it's something like a five hour
drive
so we come back and by the time we come
back almost i
i don't remember the dates great on this
but almost as quickly as we got back
it was hey jocko the cpa in the job is
getting overrun
it's on already and they you know we're
sending you down there as qrf
which to me qrf five hours
this is not a qrf and well they didn't
have a helicopter they said
you know hey we want you to drive down
there and i'm like
roger that 10 hours of driving yeah and
i'm like roger that you know like
you you want me to do something i'm
gonna do it you know
unless it just makes no sense whatsoever
so i did i did push back a little bit
like wait a second
you mean of all the units that are
between baghdad and najaf
there's not you're you're the i'm the
best option you've got with no armor
and the answer was like yep and i said
cool roger that
and i remember this my
task unit s my task unit senior enlisted
advisor who was a who i mentioned
earlier who is a
good friend of mine who at this point on
the deployment was like
you know uh we we joke about it and
we joke about it the fact that his wife
would call me
his uh he says he says we're
soul mates right so we're like total
bros
and for whatever reason he
was not going with us like they didn't
send the task unit commander
or the because when he did the hit the
task unit commander came with us and you
know he's the he's the
ground force commander i'm just the
assault force commander well for this
one for whatever reason probably because
he could those guys could provide us
better support
if they weren't with us if they were
kind of like monitoring what was
happening
if we needed it they stayed so as i'm
i'm leaving
uh i'm getting ready to you know like
load up my home v and
and my sea my senior enlisted advisor
who's my pro
like hugs me and i was like oh
damn and and the reason is because the
cpa was getting overrun and we were
going down there
to do an alamo and like my direction to
the guys was
get all the ammo that we have everyone
get a machine gun a heavy machine gun as
many as we have
you know the rockets the whole nine
yards like where this is what's
happening
and that's what we did we loaded up
and gave my gave my senior list advisor
a hug
loaded up the vehicles we rolled down
there and by the time we got down there
was over
uh you know it took us five hours to get
down there we got down there we
hung out for the night
nothing zero happened and then we drove
back
uh and that was right around
it would have been probably about the
day you were driving back is when first
fallujah started probably
april 4th no no no no no no
the uh like the the articles i've seen
had your operation on april 2nd but
maybe that's not right
wait i don't no i don't think fallujah
one went down right then
it was just a few days after um the
31st was when the blackwater guys got
taken okay it was in the weekend oh okay
you're just you're just referring to
that that initial kind of push into
fallujah the initial one that got called
off after three days
okay yes yes so that was happening
um as we're doing what we were doing
yep and and so now
now i mean i'm within a few days of
i don't know when i came home but i'm
within like where we're we're starting
to know that we're going home
i may have even sent a couple guys home
at this point like guys we're starting
to
to to head back home um and
i remember we got they were started we
started getting attacked on our base
fairly regularly we got some mortar
attacks we got some rocket attacks
uh we had the main like one of the gates
right by us get
assaulted you know where myself and that
senior enlisted advisor like we drove
out there with our guns and there's you
know tracer fire coming over the road
and we're like okay so it's on and there
was a burning vehicle that had been
stopped that was a vehicle born ied
suspected vehicle born id
and then actually so this is where i was
gonna that all happened that's this
thing where the gate got attacked
prior to that myself and my senior
enlisted advisor
we were in a tower and we were just
looking out
and there was
there was um like you could see
one of the major routes one of the major
highways out there
and there was like five or six
smoking vehicles and this was they were
probably five miles away but like you
could see
distinctly there was multiple
vehicles that had been attacked and then
our gates getting attacked
and you
you got the shia blowing up in the south
you've got the sunnis
starting to really get wild in fallujah
and um and it's time for you to go home
and are you i mean how do is there
are you locked into like your missions
enough that your blinders run are you
kind of aware that like you're leaving
at a time when this country's starting
to fall apart
well this is the first time when i start
thinking to myself i may be back here
you know if you asked me on
in march if you ask me march if i was
going to come back so so one month prior
you know if you asked me march 1st if i
would be coming back to iraq i'd be like
no this thing will be over
this thing will be over if you ask me
april whatever
april 5th april 7th if i was coming back
i'd be like yeah there's probably a good
chance i'm coming back here
because you could see things i mean
literally
see things before my very eyes that
indicated
this was gonna get this was gonna get
western real quick
came back in mid-april sometime around
then
here's a maybe indication is uh where
were you when abu ghraib hit the news
i don't know you'd have to tell me when
i was ready april 28th
to the end of the month so you it wasn't
like something where it hit you you
remember where you were when it hit that
kind of thing
you know i think that we
were home i think that we were home and
by the way abu ghraib was one of those
areas that was a bad bad area
so when i remember when i first heard
about abu ghraib i thought a little bit
about the prison because we used to send
our prisoners there sometimes
but it was a bad area abu ghraib was a
bad area they took a lot of casualties
up there
and so when i first heard of the news i
heard about abu ghraib
i thought well you know what's going on
up there in terms of like has there been
attacks
and so the thing that spun out from that
we'll talk about that next episode but
is where
i would say what you had was what you
had between
fallujah yakubi which was sodders
lieutenant
between those two things the the the the
attack on the
contractors and yokubi
what you had with those two things was a
massive
spark like a big massive spark
that actually was a little bit more than
a spark that was like a like a um
it was a spark and it started some
kindling was on fire and it was burning
pretty bright but it was
still you could step on it you could
step on it and you might have been able
to put it out
maybe maybe not
but what abu ghraib ended up i think
being was a massive amount of fuel on
the fire
yeah yeah
and i suppose we can talk about that one
yeah that's a that's a topic in itself
next time um if you want to check out
our other podcasts
i have a podcast called jocko podcast i
have a podcast for kids called the
warrior kid podcast
and i have a podcast called grounded
which is about
well it's about jiu jitsu in life and
then daryl
has a podcast which is called martyr
made
and you can also support this podcast
by getting some gear from jockostore.com
or getting gear from a little place
called
origin maine.com
that if you help those companies
you'll be helping us so we can keep
doing this and all of our other podcasts
with that thanks for listening
as things unravel
this is jocko and daryl out